so this is the first year we've ever
looked at the top paid oscar-nominated
actors and actresses
normally we just look at the top paid
actors and actresses across the whole
entertainment industry
and historically those folks are not
getting nominated for oscars um those
are the folks doing
big budget action film superhero movies
those are not necessarily
the the folks doing prestige oscar bait
but we did decide this year to take a
look at these nominees
and our theory kind of proved true that
you have to decide do you want to make a
prestige film
for the sake of art or because it's an
important message
or because you want to win an award like
something like trial of the chicago
seven or mahreni's black bottom or do
you want to choose
money you want to do something like the
fast and furious movies or wonder woman
for some perspective all five top
earning oscar nominated actors made a
collective
41 million over the past 12 months last
year
the top paid actor dwayne johnson earned
87.5 million
dollars in just 12 months so that's more
than double what these five combined
actors
mean so there really is this dichotomy
in hollywood
sasha baron cohen i think is the most
surprising he's the top paid actor
with 22 million this year and most of
that almost all of it
is coming from borat the subsequent
movie film
and he is nominated for that film for
screenwriting but
i think it kind of is just funny you
know
that project is mockumentary and and to
think that that is how he's making most
of his money rather than
the prestigious trial of the chicago
seven that was pretty surprising and
funny
viola davis is number two with seven
million and she was
the only person on this list who was
also on last year's list of top paid
actors or actresses and that's honestly
mainly because of how to get away with
murder she can command top dollar for
that and she also has
a l'oreal campaign what she's nominated
for which is my rainey's black bottom
she actually was you know probably when
we got paid around
3 million for that and that's even after
coming off of her
last august wilson adoption for fences
which she won an oscar for so
that's kind of interesting that the
small screen is actually paying her the
big bucks
chadwick boseman comes in at five
million number three on our list
he died tragically in august from colon
cancer at age 43 but if you hear stories
from people
on set with him he gave it his all until
his final days and he is nominated for
his final film which is mahrini's black
bottom which he stars in alongside viola
davis it was released posthumously
and because he's such a certified
commercial star
he really could command three or four
million dollars for that role which is
impressive for such a small budget this
is his first oscar nomination though
and he also collected a check this year
for a supporting role in
spike lee's defy floods an oscar win or
even a nomination can be the
perfect mix of publicity and validation
to increase future earnings potential
take someone like angelina jolie who won
the oscar in 1999 for her performance in
girl interrupted
prior to that she was starring in
independent films
not really these big blockbusters but in
2001 after that oscar win she played the
titular character in lara croft tomb
raider
by 2004 she was commanding 10 million
dollars per roll
and last year she was the world's second
highest paid actress with 35.5
million dollars in earnings and she made
around 20 million just for
her one role in maleficent ii
you